thron was born into a poor family among
the chis a group of bl- skinned red-eyed
individuals thron later became an
officer for the chis ascendency and
actually briefly worked with Anakin
Skywalker on a mission on bat two which
is the setting of The Black Spire
Outpost in Disney's Galaxy's Edge when
the Clone Wars ended and the Empire came
to power thron offered his services to
the Empire thron quickly Rose through
the ranks of the Empire and was granted
the title of grand Admiral by Palpatine
himself which was a pretty big deal
because the empire was known to be
xenophobic and only promote humans to
high ranking positions thron's in was
further displayed in the book Thon
ascendency in which he deduces that
Darth Vader and Anakin Skywalker are the
same person he recognizes Vader by the
way he flies as fighter in a specific
barrel role which was the same as a
maneuver performed by Anakin Skywalker
in the opening scene of Revenge of the
Sith Thon later became the commanding
officer of the seventh fleet and led the
fight against the rebels in the lothal
sector during the Galactic Civil War and
during the final battle his ship was
pulled into hyperspace by A Flock of
Pergo creatures taking thraw and the
Padawan Ezra Bridger deep into the
unknown regions